welcome to ces
i'm thrilled to introduce today's
keynote speaker amd president and chief
executive officer
dr lisa sue she's also was just
recognized as fortune's number two most
powerful business person of the year
she is known for making big bets leading
disciplined execution against ambitious
road maps
forging meaningful partnerships and
accelerating the growth and trajectory
of amd
lisa sue has made a name for herself as
an industry leader who is pursuing
cutting-edge technologies
that change the world amd products
and technologies are helping to redefine
the technology industry
we already see that through its work
with pcs where amd technology has helped
people to reimagine the future of
education
entertainment gaming and work as it
continues to push the envelope on
performance
and in the cloud where amd technology
powers some of the most important
services
from video conferencing to video
streaming
it's hard to tour the all digital ces
and not see something that amd
is a part of from powerful desktops used
by content creators
to notebooks and chromebooks that have
assisted in the virtual schooling of
children everywhere
to your favorite new game consoles amd
touches so many facets of life-changing
technology
sue is an engineer technologist and
problem solver
at heart who has always been driven to
find meaningful solutions
to challenges in successfully advancing
leading-edge semiconductor
and high-performance computing
technologies throughout her career
prior to joining amd dr sue held
technology and business leadership
positions at ibm
and freescale semiconductor now nxp
i'm excited to welcome dr lisa sue to
ces
technology changes the world
but not on its own
hardware needs heart
software needs soul
when processing power means brain power
tomorrow comes alive
a thousand ideas spark inside one mind
the world shrinks
horizons expand
[Music]
the speed of progress leaves us
breathless
with high performance computing to lift
us
[Music]
we see more possibilities
new opportunities
[Music]
we see
[Music]
where the future starts
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone thank you to gary and
to all of you for joining us today at
ces 2021
it's an honor to keynote ces for the
second time
i know for most of us we start every
january together so doing a virtual
keynote is certainly different
at ces last year none of us could have
imagined all the things that would
happen in 2020
as we navigated the covid19 pandemic
globally i know it was a challenging
year for everyone
but it was also a year where we
experienced firsthand
the increasingly important role
technology plays in every aspect of our
lives
for all of us in the tech industry
although we've had our set of challenges
2020 was perhaps one of our most
productive years
from how we work to how our kids learned
to our entertainment
to accelerating the pace of our digital
transformation
high performance computing has never
been more important in our daily lives
or to our future the world needed us to
turbo charge our technology capabilities
and our industry delivered wonderfully
in so many different ways
at amd our focus has always been to push
the envelope on high performance
computing
across the cloud infrastructure and
personal computing and in 2020 we
broadened our focus to ensure we were
working with our partners to drive
innovation
provide more capability and meet the new
requirements of a digital first world
i'm most proud of the work we have done
with technology applied to solve some of
the world's most challenging research
problems
a great example of this is a work in the
scientific community
scientists and researchers really
pivoted on a dime to pull their
resources to rally around
research on vaccines therapeutics and
other important learnings to combat and
understand the pandemic
and to help them do this the amd kovit
19 hpc fund
donated over 12 petal flops of
supercomputing last year
to many of the world's leading
universities and labs conducting
infectious disease research
let's hear from some of the researchers
on their work
when the pandemic came along there was a
remarkable moment
almost overnight it seemed the
researchers that had been working on
various
other applications changed their
research quickly to address covert more
directly
i've never seen such a universal desire
to reach out across
disciplines to form these
interdisciplinary collaborations to try
to do what we can
to understand this virus to understand
the covenanting disease and to help
overcome the pandemic i'm the director
of the koran institute of mathematical
sciences
i'm an associate professor of molecular
biosciences
we run the big computers we do high
performance computing
i am a professor in the department of
mathematics and statistics
there's never enough computing available
there's always a huge demand
that is where the amd donation really
comes into play
it's going to allow us to take all of
this big data and make sense of it
the hardware will enable
scientific breakthroughs because it has
been designed specifically
to be an ai capable machine the fact
that
this new platform that's being provided
by amd can do this quadrillion
calculations per second
you know will really allow us to build
more sophisticated models
high performance computing that can
process massive amounts of data
and then couple it to simulations to
make predictions
it could be just a game changer we're
going to have the capability of feeding
all of these parameters the molecular
parameters cellular parameters clinical
parameters from patients
into machine learning algorithms we're
now not limited anymore
by how quickly those machine learning
algorithms can run because of how
powerful these new gpu clusters are jobs
that used to take
weeks on a supercomputer to run can
happen in a matter of hours
when you're dealing with a pandemic time
is important and getting solutions and
ideas and possible
you know therapeutics and drugs as soon
as you can is a paramount importance
we have many people across 55
departments or more than 55 departments
in fact
that are doing covid related research
the researchers
made these rapid changes in their work
and i think that speaks to the
generality of the machine learning
methods but also to the power of the
computing
and then amd came along with this
remarkable
gift of tremendous additional computing
power at just the right time
to help us accelerate the research
results that leads to real answers
the industry ability to partner with
universities
is a real boon to scientific development
it's a really exciting time to be doing
science where the computer is really a
part of the experiment
can take us to places we never expected
we'd be able to go
people feel like they're a partner
they're part of something important they
all you know drop what they have to do
and they go work on this thing
we're all in it together and that is
just something really really nice to see
those researchers truly are inspiring
and you know that what they're learning
will not only help in this pandemic
but will actually position us much much
better for the future
now when the pandemic hit our lives
actually changed
practically overnight as we went to
working schooling and sheltering at home
in many businesses digital
transformations that typically would
have taken years to complete
were adopted in a matter of weeks or
months and while these shifts were
challenging on a personal level
the differences were dramatic on the
planet just take a look at some of the
satellite data
this shows the level of harmful
emissions in the skies over europe
fewer people on the roads meant
significantly reduced emissions
improved air quality and visibly less
smog
at the same time we transitioned to the
new normal of working and schooling from
home
we've all needed to adapt to new ways of
communicating and collaborating which
has placed significantly higher demands
on our digital infrastructure
and made devices like the pc even more
essential so if you take a look at some
of the user stats
zoom users are now approaching three and
a half trillion minutes of meetings per
year
cisco webex meeting participants
recently hit 600 million per month
and microsoft teams is now supporting
115 million daily active users
all of these examples make it clear how
over the last year our relationship with
technology
has fundamentally changed the pandemic
has elevated technology to become an
essential part
of how we live work play and communicate
and at the center of all this technology
is high performance computing
that's why i'm very excited today to be
joined by leaders from several of the
industry's most important companies to
share
their perspective on the technology
trends and products that will define
2021.
together we'll show you how advances in
high performance computing will once
again reset
expectations for what's possible across
pcs
gaming and the data center so with that
as an introduction let's get started
with one of our biggest partners and a
company that plays
a significant role across each of these
markets to talk more about our work
together
please welcome microsoft chief product
officer panos pane
hi lisa hey panos it's so good to see
you thank you for joining me today
well i think i've connected with you uh
quite a bit over the past few months on
microsoft teams so i feel like i see you
in the screen all the time we definitely
learned to work together this way for
sure
so look um you know it's been an
incredible time in the world
and you know certainly for tech um you
know microsoft is at the center of that
and really empowering people
you know can you tell me a little bit
about what it's been like for you and
the team at microsoft these last 10
months
you know like many people at microsoft
they're learning to work differently and
i you know i feel that
certainly i mean yesterday i was in a
meeting uh with satya my dogs were
barking in the background the garage
door open
and you know you're kind of working
through it i think like everybody we're
still adapting still learning
takes time you know how we connect uh
with each other is changing right now
lisa in a
huge way how we work is changing how we
learn is changing
you know so school work even how we're
gaming which is so important to what we
do together
uh you know and then ultimately we're
seeing that
you know at microsoft that pc it's
becoming
more essential than it's ever been
before but not only as a
productivity tool but as a tool to
connect with other humans and people in
general
whether it's at school or work and you
see that you just said it you know as we
work together it's
super powerful because we can continue
to move forward continue to push the
boundaries
and i think between our companies it's
our it's our responsibility to help
tech disappear into the background and
help people do that connection our
customers need that right now more than
ever and so
we can talk about how folks are kind of
working at microsoft but then you can
see this intensity of usage of our
products together
that's really coming to life how we
support that day in and day out
matters but how we look to the future
also and to your point you know whether
it's uh the intensity on teams or
windows or
azure on the back end supporting so much
or just the delight of being able to
game
on a pc or an xbox right now that you
know you you have a whole
whole team at microsoft a whole company
if you will
kind of rallying around uh how to help
people stay connected
work play uh and learn and ultimately
being able to partner with
with amd has been phenomenal for us well
look i think um you know upon us
actually i think we see it exactly the
same way it's such a special time
where we can really use technology um to
help people do all the things that they
need to do
and uh and frankly it is how we stay
connected so
you know um i'm so proud of the work
that we've done together it's you know
our partnership is just incredibly broad
and uh you know spans all the way from
you know
cloud and data center to you know
console gaming
and then you know to windows and surface
um it's just been you know so great to
partner with
your team so can you talk a little bit
about some of the the uh the
co-engineering and what uh we're trying
to accomplish
yeah i think it'd be great i'd love to i
first let me just say amd's momentum
right now is incredible
uh the the impact you're having on the
world the work you've done
uh let me just say that i can and truly
from the most humblest
place like we've been working together
lisa for a long time you and i
uh but before i get into any of that i
would we just we should start right now
when you talk partnerships we gotta
start with gaming don't we
working on the xbox series x and series
s
uh these this work doesn't happen in a
silo this is two teams getting together
getting
right down to the depth of what it means
to deliver an incredible gaming
experience
uh now we have this incredibly the most
performant console
on the planet and that's the work we do
together i think some people just think
it
you know sometimes i hear it just
happens no these are two teams coming
together
working in detail then take it to the
next level the work you're doing with
azure the detailed work
with amd and azure coming together with
epic delivering for game pass
and xcloud like these are real depth
partnerships
and here's my favorite thing and the way
we work together and for those of you
who don't know like you can take that
architecture and that thinking that
drives the xbox
uh the rdna architecture if you will our
dna2 i think and you just
move that into what is the pc like
and that's that's what just now i get
super excited of course because
you know how much i love windows uh how
much i love working on these products
um leading into your radeon product
which has been so incredibly powerful
for the pc right now to help gamers
push forward you know the to help the
high performance pc compute
happen and right now think about
customers in this time you know we have
an intensity of usage this is even cat
at home or gaming at home
being able to push 64 core computing
with threadripper you're doing all that
with us
but it's really the detailed work of the
two teams coming together to bring that
to life
but let me also share with you we
created a small video for you lisa i
knew what we were coming on today i
thought boy it'd be so fun
yeah i'd love to see it
[Music]
[Music]
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanos that was fantastic thank you
again for joining us was great to see
you
and thanks for providing uh those uh
those insights for our audience
what a blast lisa thank you for having
me i really am grateful and thank you
for this partnership
i think amd is doing amazing things
right now and your tech is moving this
world forward and we're so grateful for
it
now let's turn our attention to pcs in
2020
approximately 300 million notebooks
desktops and chromebooks were sold
that's the highest number since 2014 and
we expect demand to be even higher in
2021 as the pc continues playing
an even larger role in our daily lives
at amd
we believe the pc has never been more
essential now last november we
introduced our first processors powered
by our new zen3 cpu core
zen3 is a new architecture that brings
new capabilities to pcs while delivering
leadership performance and energy
efficiency
the zen 3 core is a phenomenal example
of amd's dedication to building the best
technology
we redesigned the core to deliver our
largest generation over generation
performance increase since we launched
the zen family
zen 3 increases our lead in overall
performance and energy efficiency and
also delivers the best single threaded
performance
as a result the ryzen 5000 series cpus
are the fastest processors in the world
for gamers and creators
now we designed zen 3 to scale from
ultra thin notebooks all the way up to
super computers
and i'm excited to announce we're
starting 2021 by launching the most
powerful pc processors ever built
for ultra thin and gaming notebooks
today i'm proud to introduce
the amd ryzen 5000 series mobile
processors powered by our new zen3 core
these new chips offer both tremendous
performance and long battery life
in fact amd is the only company with an
eight core x86
processor for ultra thins for many years
the notebook pc market was on an
incremental pace
by combining our leadership design
capabilities with seven nanometer
process technology
our 4000 series mobile processors
launched last year
set a new performance trajectory for
notebook processors
and we continue that new performance
trajectory in 2021 with our ryzen 5000
series mobile processors
you can expect to do more to be more
productive and to have more immersive
gaming experiences
with a notebook powered by our new ryzen
mobile processors
now with so many of us working and
learning from home in 2020
the performance and capabilities of our
home pc
actually defined how we worked and how
we learned and much of our social
interaction
we saw our productivity our ability to
create
and our opportunities to connect limited
by the computing power of our pc
and for many of us we wanted more our
new amd ryzen 5000 series mobile
processors for ultra thin notebooks will
be a significant step forward in
performance and efficiency
with up to eight of our news n3 cores
the amd
ryzen 5000 series are the best
processors in the world for thin and
light notebooks
whether you're running general office
productivity applications or more cpu
intensive tasks like video rendering
photo editing or 3d design the ryzen
5000 series actually sets the new bar
for leadership performance now the amd
ryzen 7 5800u
is our best ultra thin notebook
processor it has
eight cores 16 threads with a boost up
to 4.4 gigahertz
and all of this while operating within a
15 watt thermal design that's required
for these ultra-thin notebooks now when
you take a look at the benchmarks across
a large range of applications it's just
very clear that the ryzen 7 5800u
just runs your software faster it's a
very special product the
fastest x86 processor in the world for
thin and light notebooks
now the performance is really great but
in the notebook form factor
battery life is also extremely important
and this is where the energy efficiency
of the zen 3 core truly shines
we've just done a ton of optimization in
this space and with the ryzen 5000
series you can expect
up to 17 and a half hours of general use
and 21 hours of video playback on a
single charge
now that's a major jump compared to our
previous generation
and true all-day battery life now
notebook customers don't just buy thin
and light laptops
but millions of people actually buy
notebooks to play pc games
amd has a rich history in pc gaming and
deep ties to the gaming community
gamers actually want desktop-like
performance in the notebook form factor
and that's exactly what we built our new
hx series mobile processors
raise the bar for gaming notebooks the
hx brand
actually represents our commitment to
build the best processors for gaming
they feature the same zen 3 cores from
our best in class ryzen 5000 desktop
processors that deliver leadership frame
rates they're also unlocked for
overclocking and have higher thermal
ratings for sustained performance which
is key for gaming
now let me introduce you to our top of
the line ryzen 9 hx processors
the 5900 hx boosts up to 4.6 gigahertz
while the 5980hx boosts up to 4.8
gigahertz
both with eight cores and thermal design
power of 45 watts or higher
so now let's take a look at the ryzen
5900 hx in action
what you're looking at here is a very
graphics intensive game
horizon zero dawn running on our new
ryzen 5900 hx processor
we're running this game at 1080p with a
high detail preset to really stress the
cpu
and as you can see our new mobile hx
processors are delivering smooth frame
rates of over 100 frames per second
and for all of you looking for a mobile
4k experience i'm happy to report that
gaming notebooks featuring our new hx
processors
are also capable of delivering smooth
gaming experiences
when running at 4k at high settings now
turning to some benchmarks versus a
competition
whether you're talking about single
threaded performance or overall cpu
performance
the ajax series wins by a wide margin
this is why the best gaming notebooks of
2021 will be powered by amd
ryzen mobile hx processors to bring the
ryzen 5000 mobile processors to market
we're really pleased with the strong
partnership with the industry's leading
pc oems
this year we expect the number of
notebook designs powered by our new
generation of ryzen mobile processors to
grow
by 50 compared to the ryzen 4000 series
we expect more than 150 ultra thin
gaming and professional notebooks
powered by ryzen 5000 series to launch
this year
this means even more choice for
consumers and you won't have to wait
long to get your hands on these new
systems with the first notebooks
expected to be on sale from the world's
top notebook providers in february
we couldn't be more excited about what
the ryzen 5000 will do for you in 2021
to drive innovation in the pc market you
need great partners
our next guest leads one of the world's
largest pc companies
let's welcome hp ceo and a great friend
enrique loras
hi enrique thank you so much for joining
me today it's great to see you to start
the new year together
lisa it's great to see you as well and
congratulations for keynote in this year
in amd
and also for all the success of amd well
look we are uh so honored to be
partnered with hp
hp has uh really been at the center of
silicon valley innovation
and um during the past year you know you
and i have talked a lot about
you know really the charge that you're
leading in helping consumers and
businesses use technology to transform
the way
we live work and learn can you tell us a
little bit about some of the trends that
you've seen accelerating over the past
year
sure i think the one of the most
important things we have seen during the
last months
is that pcs have become essential with
people working from home kids learning
from home
playing from home families entertaining
from home
the pc have become really the center of
all these processes
and this is driving a new source of
innovation enabling people to do things
from their homes connecting to their
offices
really becoming much more efficient and
this is what we all have been working
together
and i think we also have learned that
it's not only about developing
technology
it's about developing technology that
everybody can access
because i think we have an obligation as
well to make sure that technology
doesn't help to divide
our current societies so this is
something that
we are working together on that i think
is very important as well
now i think you're absolutely right
enrique it's such an opportunity for us
to
offer technology to uh to help people in
all walks of life
so um look you know i think the amd hp
partnership has
um you know spanned a really broad reach
uh from
uh commercial pcs uh to ultrathin
consumer notebooks
to gaming and creator pcs so uh we just
showed everyone the new amd ryzen 5000
mobile processors and we truly
appreciate uh the deep partnership with
hp
can you tell us about some of the
designs that you're planning this year
yes and before that it's probably useful
to recap a bit
i still remember the first meeting you
and i had
when none of us were the ceos of our
companies where we were
thinking and designing the first
commercial pcs with amd and we have
really
gone a long way since this very early
conversation
six seven years ago and i think with the
launches this year we have really shown
how
much progress we have made and whether
we look at the versatility
of the new designs the security that we
have built
into the solutions and the new form
factors
and the premium the premium designs that
we are bringing
clearly we are making a difference and
we are showing what the combination of
both companies
can bring to the market now you're so
right enrique what i really appreciate
is that every year
the technology gets better the
partnership gets better and i think our
you know what we can offer our customers
gets better so
look it's a incredible time for
innovation um in the pc market and
across tech more broadly
enrique thank you so much for joining us
today um i'm you know really really
thankful for our partnership
and look forward to all the great new
devices that we'll have out in
2021 thank you
thank you lisa
now let's turn our attention to gaming
gaming has continued to grow in recent
years and 2020 was another record year
four in five u.s consumers have played a
video game in the past six months
and at 174 billion dollars in annual
revenue the gaming industry
is actually larger than the movie and
music industries combined we're now
approaching 3 billion people playing
games
that's 40 of the world's population
now gaming is at the heart of so much of
what we do at amd
gamers push us to innovate faster
because they always want more
more frames more pixels and more
immersive experiences
which is exactly what we delivered with
our new cpus and gpus and the new
generation of game consoles powered by
amd
the hottest products in the world today
are the new game consoles from microsoft
and sony
panos mentioned our work with microsoft
to build high performance cpus and gpus
for the xbox series x and series s
we're also incredibly proud of our deep
partnership with sony to power the new
playstation 5.
all these next generation consoles use
custom amd socs with ryzen and radeon
technology
console gaming has never looked better
and amd is providing the underlying
technology pushing 4k
gaming across these platforms now for pc
gamers we introduced high-end graphics
cards to the desktop pc market
at the end of 2020 with the radeon rx
6000 series
with the radeon 6900 xt 6800
xt and 6800 we have leadership at the
high end
the reviews and awards for these
products have been fantastic
and we know that millions of gamers are
excited about the rx 6000 series
whether you're building your own gaming
rig or buying a new gaming pc
we truly have the best for pc gamers
we're working with our partners to drive
a record number of premium desktop
gaming systems from oems and from system
builders
featuring our new radeon rx 6000 series
graphics cards
and our ryzen 5000 series desktop cpus
now the underlying graphics architecture
for all these new pc and console
products
is amd rdna2 with rdna 2 we really
exceeded our goals
we doubled the performance from the
first generation of our dna in 2019
and we achieved a 65 performance per
watt increase
while supporting the full dx12 ultimate
experience for gamers
the team did a great job with this
architecture and you'll see many more
products in 2021 with rd and a2
we talked about the importance of gaming
notebooks a bit earlier and we'll be
bringing our dna 2 to gaming notebooks
next
so let me show you a preview of the rdna
2 graphics architecture in a notebook
reference design
what you're looking at here is dirt 5
another demanding game
running at ultra high settings in 1440p
and what you see
is more than 60 frames per second just
beautiful
smooth gameplay we're on track to launch
the first notebooks with rdna2
in the first half of the year with our
partners and you'll also see
new mainstream rdna2 desktop graphic
card designs in the first half of the
year as well
we're very excited to have our dna 2
across the entire spectrum from consoles
to desktops to notebooks soon
now while console and pc gaming are the
most fun for some people
for others it's gorgeous content and
hollywood films
today high performance computing makes
it faster and less expensive to produce
amazing movies and tv shows my next
guest has overseen some of the most
beloved stories and characters ever
with visual effects and computer
animation powered by amd
francois chardovon is the head of
technology for lucasfilm and industrial
light and magic
hi really happy to be here lisa great to
see you thanks for joining us
so um ilm lucasfilm and amd have worked
together now
for more than a decade yet 2020 is
probably one of the most memorable
of the years that we've worked together
the demand for content is through the
roof can you tell us a little bit about
how 2020 has changed the way you work
absolutely you're right uh lucasfilm
just recently announced
um 10 new series and uh feature films
and a lot of studios are doing the same
thing the content creation is through
the roof
across all of the the major content
creators
and for ilm in particular despite
all the disruption for 2020 it's been an
incredibly busy year
and we're looking out to 2021 and it's
going to be even bigger
we built an entirely new studio from
scratch in
sydney australia to add to our four
other studios we opened a few months
before the pandemic really hit and it
was an opportunity for
rethinking from the ground up all of our
infrastructure to make sure that we're
making the best choices possible
one of the most important parts of our
infrastructure for what we do
is the render farm really the compute
firepower
that creates all of the images that you
see on screen and for cindy we decided
to go exclusively with with amd
to build our facility up and that was
something that
really empowered that studio to hit the
ground running despite all the
disruption of of 2020.
wow francois that's just fascinating i
mean just to think of all the things
that you guys have to think about
when you're you know producing you know
the best content in the world
so you know you guys were really an
early adopter of amd epic and
threadripper can you tell us a little
bit about how the tech works for you
absolutely i mean i think for us it's
really about scale
and flexibility scale just to produce
the sheer amount of content across
all of our studios where we just need as
much
firepower as possible and amd is really
focused on
building out the amount of power you can
put in any individual's hands
the amount of threads and cores that you
have available is unprecedented
and this really helps us deliver the
content that we have
that scale comes into play a whole lot
more than it ever has even for
interactive processes not just the
overnight processes
where more and more we're just seeing
software take advantage of uh
that sheer amount of threads that are
that are available with amd processors
um in a way to software it never has
before and so artists are able to make
changes and immediately see the results
that gives you
more of an intuitive sense of how when
you turn the knob
it really affects what you see on screen
that really changes how you approach
the creative process you know friend
squad you sound like you love cores and
threads just as much as i do so
we uh we love that but you know it you
know you're really um you know pushing
the envelope on
um you know what technology can do and
it sounds like
there are actually things that you can
do in your creative pipeline or workflow
that you weren't able to do before can
you tell us a little bit about that
as artists more and more having to
tackle really high resolution content
high dynamic range more bit depth it's
just a lot of data to process
and a lot of the the codecs the the
compression algorithms for the content
are becoming more and more elaborate
than they have before and being able to
play back
at speed 4k content 8k content we have
rides that are projected on huge screens
that are sometimes multiple 16k
content we've never been able to review
that before and that's an area where
we're really looking to amd to to help
us solve that problem
in in a cost-effective way that used to
be really limited to specialized
hardware
and amd is making that a whole lot more
commoditized than it
than it ever has in the past that's
fantastic really uh really exciting
stuff i know we're all looking forward
to seeing it well um you know thank you
so much uh for joining us today and
giving us
you know some of your insights on how
you know high performance computing
really does enable all the wonderful
work that uh that you do at ilm and
lucasfilm
we're really proud to be your partner
and really look forward to doing much
much more together in the future
thank you so much lisa this has been
great and amd has been an amazing
partner through all this
let's take a look at some of the great
work by lucasfilm and ilm
using high performance computing
[Music]
[Music]
to share more about our work in the pc
workstation and server markets
let's welcome our great friend lenovo
chairman and ceo yang yun-ching
why why it's great to see you today
thank you so much for joining us
thank you lisa thank you for having me
here
you know i've heard you say lenovo's
focused on building smarter technology
for all
data center pcs mobile phones and smart
devices
can you tell me a little bit about what
the lenovo team experienced in 2020 when
it comes to the world's transition
to digital first why some people
predicted the smartphone
would replace ppc and tablets before
the work and study from home trend have
proven
pc to be our essential productivity tool
now although this trend was
studied by the pandemic it has now
become
a new lifestyle so even after the
pandemic
we believe this new lifestyle will stay
and the lenovo is committed to meet
our customers requirements you know we
enjoy such a great partnership that
spans from data center to workstation to
all forms of pc
lenovo has some of the best solutions
with amd products whether it's
our ryzen 5000 or our threadripper
workstation products
or our amd epic product line how do you
view our expanding partnership and you
know what we're able to bring to
customers
in these markets we are happy to address
different customer needs
with a broader portfolio of technologies
and the solutions we create with amd
our legion gaming systems are well
recognized
by esports enthusiasts
our yoga products are the perfect blend
of
style and performance
our thinkpad and sync book allows the
professionals
take their productivity home or
anywhere and our workstations continue
to
generate the creative contents and
inspire the world that's just really
fantastic why why
you know we're starting a new year
together during our digital ces
and i know you often use ces to kick off
your most important announcements for
the year
so can you tell us about some of the
things that you're excited about for
2021
as part of our smarter technology for
our vision
we believe there should also be
connectivity for all
we have embedded the 5g technology
across a number of our products
to make sure they can be always on and
always connected
but the tunde 20 told us that
what our customers need in the new
normal
is a breakthrough in a few existing
technologies
that have become absolutely essential
today
we are leveraging advanced technology
like
artificial intelligence and the latest
hardware innovations
to drive breakthrough in this space as a
customer-centric
company lenovo is definitely focused on
innovations that makes the biggest
impact
on customers lives today and in the
future that sounds super exciting why
why
thank you again for joining us today i'm
really looking forward to all the great
new amd powered products
lenovo has in the works
we've talked about the impact of high
performance computing in our research
in our work in education gaming and
the movies but high performance
computing is also changing the world of
professional sports
amd is very proud to be an official
partner to the seven time champion
mercedes amg
formula one racing team now let's talk
to
our superstar driver lewis hamilton and
team ceo total wolf to find out how the
world of high performance computing
and auto racing and esports are coming
together lewis how are you it's so great
to see you after such a busy year
i'm well thank you thanks so much for
having me well look
first congratulations on your
record-tying seventh formula one drivers
championship
just simply amazing toto thanks for
joining us and congratulations to you as
well for winning your seventh
constructors championship as a team
thank you for having me i'm pleased to
join you
and yeah it was a another good season we
won a seventh constructor championship
it was a difficult year with kovite 19
but finally on track
we were successful well it's fantastic i
know it was um
such a grueling year but you guys were
just amazing
and uh hey one of the things i know
about you is that you love gaming
and uh amd loves gaming too in fact i
heard you might be having some fun in
your down time with your new amd powered
sony playstation 5.
yes absolutely um yeah i've actually
always been
uh my dad was actually um
uh he was always into computers and when
he when uh when i was younger when we
started racing he
he worked on computers for the british
rail and then he uh
got into his own it and network support
company so
i remember being at home growing up and
my dad taken apart these
uh the pcs and i remember getting
involved and learning how to
to build computers for him when i was
started working with when i was 17
i was always always into gaming and
watching the technology advance over the
years has been
absolutely mind-blowing and um
yes of course i couldn't i've been
nagging everyone for the ps5 like
everyone is
and i finally got it and i actually
carry it around with me um
i travel with it everywhere i go and i
have a a real
a gaming monitor the whole headphone i'm
fully geared up i'm just imagining that
imagine you're getting into the zone
with your uh ps5 so that's wonderful
um look you know one of the reasons amd
is an official partner to your team is
that
formula one is such a great application
of high performance computing technology
can you just tell me a little bit about
your view of the role of technology
in racing and how the team depends
on partners like um our computing
technology well it's incredible when
people look at the the image next to you
of the formula one car
you know everything is built in-house
pretty much everything is built in-house
uh give or take the tires and maybe
breaks but
majority of the stuff is designed
in-house and built in-house and
designed on cad machines we
you know the technology in terms of um
that the software they use for
aero data analysis um
you we have a real wind tunnel and then
we have a virtual wind tunnel
and the crazy amount of computing power
that takes place for that
is is insane to see and it's advancing
all the time
and um from weekends each weekend
there's a
huge amount of download i think it's
over 500
gigabytes of downloaded data which
gets transferred back to the back to the
uk to headquarters
is digested um we're running
a huge amount of simulations through the
weekends
in terms of getting the the right setup
strategy from a driver's point of view
to get it ahead you need to understand
um the data
that's understanding the the uh all the
controls i have over 20 buttons on my
steering wheel
that have a direct link to how the car
behaves
so i'm studying that in the background
on computers
all the time and also when we come back
into the garage
the car downloads and the data pops up
on my screen
and i'm having to doubt uh i mean having
to
push that technology to be fast the
faster we can get that the faster i can
analyze it and the faster i can get back
out there
and uh and and improve so
it's it's a huge part and and huge asset
for us and
um i'm super grateful that we we have
amd with us
oh it'll be uh fantastic to watch we're
looking forward to it
so our work with you and the team goes
much deeper than seeing the amd
brand on the beautiful w11 car you know
from the computing needed to design the
setup and set up the cars to the
notebooks and desktops that the team
uses
on track and everywhere in between can
you talk a little bit about how you're
using
our technology as a team yes so it goes
much beyond
the sticker on the car like we call it
the marketing
and branding benefit is just the icing
on the cake
what is really beneficial in our
relationship is there is only a few
of these partnerships that we have is
the technic collaboration and the
advantage that you provide to us
and it's not only hardware like the
desktops or the notebooks it's
really ingrained or it's making its way
into our performance departments
be it in the vehicle dynamic group or
in aerodynamics into the simulation um
we're starting to really integrate amd
products and that should give us an
advantage
against our direct competitors well we
love to be part of that advantage
and that toto you're responsible for not
just the formula one team but the
formula e team as well as the esports
team
and i know many of our viewers here are
very interested in esports so can you
talk a little bit about how you're using
technology there
we have been growing our department
around
esports from something that was a little
bit trial and error a few years ago
to a real professional team and we see
the audiences growing massively and it
has become an area of performance
like with the real car so it's all about
simulation
it's about development and the setup of
the car
and there again without wanting to
disclose our competitive advantage
you have been part of our success and we
we count on you
that's uh super super cool um lewis and
toto thank you so much it's been such an
honor to have you join us today
and best of luck in the new season i'm
really looking forward to our
partnership continuing
and seeing what happens as we go through
the year yes
we are really happy and proud to have
you on board and
you help us with the competitive
edge and yes thank you very much for
having me
now let's turn our attention to one of
the most important areas of high
performance computing
the data center cloud and super
computing during our 2019 ces keynote we
demonstrated the world's first
64 core x86 server processor
since then amd epic processors have been
adopted by the largest cloud service
providers
the fastest supercomputers and in the
heart of the enterprise
in addition to the researchers we heard
from earlier using amd technologies for
medical research
our epic processors are also being used
for research in areas like weather
forecasting
climate change and energy exploration
from aws
to google to microsoft tencent cloud
and oracle the largest cloud providers
have adopted epic processors to power
their internal infrastructure and
services
and that incredible growth and video
collaboration i highlighted earlier
those two are powered by amd epic
including services like microsoft teams
running on azure
and while each of these customers has
unique needs and requirements they all
share one thing in common
they will take as much computing power
as they can get and they all want more
that's why we're so excited about our
upcoming 3rd gen epic processors
3rd gen epic will reset the bar for data
center computing
with up to 64 leadership zen 3 cores our
next generation server processors
extend our leadership in performance
total cost of ownership
and security but today we want to give
you the world's first preview of the
upcoming processors codename milan
running wrf one of the most popular
tools used for
climate research and weather forecasting
wrf is used in 185 countries
and as you might expect to simulate
something as complex as a weather system
wrf is an extremely demanding
application that benefits
for more processing power let's take a
look at the competitive performance of
our upcoming milan processors running a
simulation
in this test we're comparing two
comparably configured servers running a
compute intensive weather forecast
for the continental united states the
system on the right
features two of our next generation 32
core milan processors
and the system on the left features two
of the highest end dual socket
processors from our competition
we're taking in a large set of climate
data to produce a six hour weather
forecast
and what you see is that the additional
performance of the amd epic processors
completes the simulation much much
faster the third gen epic server
completed the forecast
68 faster than the competition
and the speed to complete in this case
is very important
because if the simulation runs faster it
means scientists improve the accuracy of
the forecast
by using a larger data set for the model
or running more simulations per day
now just imagine how much more
performance you're going to see
with two 64 core milan processors we're
extremely excited about bringing third
gen epic to market and can't wait to
show you more
when we launch later this quarter now
it's been so much fun today but it's
time to wrap this up
i'm so thankful for our amazing partners
who joined us today
panos panet from microsoft enrique loris
from hp
francois heart of juan from lucasfilm
ilm
yy from lenovo and lewis hamilton and
toto wolff from mercedes amg formula one
today we've seen the power of high
performance computing from scientific
research
to education to global business to auto
racing
to gaming and filmmaking i hope you're
leaving with the same excitement that i
have
i'm really proud to be part of this
amazing industry and when we work
together
across disciplines the technology that
we build can make a huge
impact on people's lives amd and our
partners will continue to push the
envelope on high performance computing
in 2021 and the years ahead
thank you for joining me today and have
a fantastic digital ces
[Music]
experience
[Music]
you